[Music]
well i just want to say that the
clutter of my office makes the clutter
of your office look like
a freaking this is awesome
carefully curated clutter yours is like
throw that in there with the rest of the
refuse end of my husband
wow no i mine is more like i'm gonna
need that
so why don't i keep it within arm's
reach we're heading into the side
and this week in the side we're going to
analyze uh
chickpea or garbanzo beans
are you this is this we've done this in
the past it's called just the facts
ma'am
just in fact machines
uh were technology that existed you know
i wanted to send
andy a script page i would have needed a
fax a fax machine
or a telex yes um this
that kind of facts andy no why it's
facts about the year 2000
i mean 2020 that don't suck see what i'm
doing i'm putting a positive spin
on one of the worst years in american
history you take a [ __ ] page out of
professor andrew mcelfisch's book kids
and then that people won't know what
happened on that page
you're taking the page out waiting
waiting
professor book kids
professor oh not a real professor jesus
christ well
i told you you had one in the chamber
and you didn't even let me say it before
saying that already
2021 is the year i stopped correcting
everybody and i let them
think i am a real professor
this is 2021 first of all um
i i think uh yeah you're right good
thing all right
what was good about 2020 i dare you to
find
something well the first the first one
is a blessing in disguise okay
that um theater attendance due to the
covet 19 uh worldwide pandemic
was down so much that popcorn
kernel manufacturers had an enormous
surplus so now we have a strategic
popcorn kernel reserve of more than
a dozen giant silos
in iowa and other states in the midwest
that is silos that used to be filled
with nuclear warheads now
filled with kernels
and the uh the residual uranium
actually pops the kernels and they no it
doesn't know what else
pots earl butts dream of a
surplus of corn american corn has
finally come to fruition ladies and
gentlemen
we now have more popcorn kernels than we
know what to do with can they be turned
into other things andy
they can become popcorn generals if they
apply themselves
i got nothing it's friday all jokes must
go
all the dad jokes um all right that's a
good point that's a good point about
2020.
but it kind of tells you can you imagine
people
eat that much popcorn at the movie
theater this is not like
over redenbacher sticking them in those
weird little bags and you
put them in the microwave if people eat
that much popcorn andy think of how many
silos full of ass we could fill right
now because
i thought you would start with at least
mike and ikes but no he went straight to
the ass
i always do ask my wife but the uh it's
it's
it's
nobody could get together if you can't
make popcorn and go to the movies and
eat popcorn
your damn skippy ain't eating ass so can
you look up
the is that your formula yeah figures on
how
i were to if i wanted to eat ass i know
a movie theater will be involved
what's another fact to it from 2020
before we begin
but there's a great invention that uh we
will actually become a consumer
invention pretty soon at nasa
they created what is being nicknamed as
the iron man
glove do tell what is it for
fisting because i want out if it's
fisting but if it's for heroics i want
it
okay well it's not for fisting
by the way nothing is for fisting even a
fist just stop it
there's always a time for fisting that's
my waterloo commercial there's always a
time
for fisting you want to lose
with waterloo why don't you say it's
always time for waterloo i'm like
we're gonna remember that but they'll
remember somebody
like it's always time for fistic like
you know what he's a marketing genius
wow
yeah i didn't get the name of the
product right though so if i say genius
i say more of a
confused genius he's a modern-day don
draper and as much as like you know he
comes up with a somewhat clever idea but
he goes california all the time
and he goes straight for the ass
[Laughter]
silos full of the kids yes uh
well it's an it's an iron it's a glove
that you put on your hand obviously
yes and it's powered giving the person
wearing it
the gripping strength that is 15 times
stronger than the
grip strength you put into it and it's
really like just like
all amazing technologies can be used for
masturbation
listen i didn't the thought crossed my
mind that you might go there
for sure deciding to put this on the
list what's the gripping power on this
[ __ ] let me see if i can handle
it
turn it up pop
whoo it was worth it
so using that is to be used in uh outer
space like on the space station to do
things where
you know in those those awkward gloves
that you have you need
extra strength and you know why because
they're inflated
in a spacesuit the gloves are inflated
and so your fingers claw at the inside
and don't really get to do very much
good out there and so you use tools for
everything
now with this you'll have the strength
inside that glove to use the glove and
use it for
things that you would normally do with
your fingers and you can take that
sentence wherever you like
crush an enemy's throat man in battle
and [ __ ] like that
what are you wearing why are you wearing
an inflated suit because you're
in space space yeah right so it's like
third act of moon record and you gotta
kick some ass you james bond jaws is
coming at you with them teeth you've got
this [ __ ] iron man power glove
you crossing the streams giving me the
bond aversions
we all win
all right what else happened good in
2020 um
you know you think you know everything
about sperm cells
i don't know so from the time of leo and
hoke
there's an early user of the microscope
people have thought that he described
that sperm cells
slither because he had them on a slide
with another glass over it and they had
to wriggle under it
it turns out they corkscrew
so they go whooshing through the water
like a corkscrew
like that is that right yeah so it's not
no whippy little tail
the whippy tail is actually making them
go in a corkscrew pattern
so we only see the whippy tail on a flat
slide back and forth goes back and forth
but really that [ __ ] is doing
like
haymakers yeah because it's like we
gotta get there
we gotta [ __ ] wait don't we die how
come if sperm feel that [ __ ]
motivated like i will accomplish or die
what happens to us we get here and we're
like that was enough
could you imagine all that corkscrewing
in the tail don't mean [ __ ] when you're
sliding down someone's gullet into their
skull
it's their [ __ ] stomach acids now how
good are you
good swimmers corkscrews
just to be clear here that's what you
get for leaving home
sperm
all right now this one is uh
there's a i'm putting a silver lining on
the dark fact here you know global
climate change used to be called global
warming but they call it climate change
now because
every time it's cold on a day people are
like oh
well global warming it's it's cold today
but last year they set a record in
siberia
siberia that's like the best place to be
in russia
every russian wants to go there that's
like malibu of russia baby
if i go to siberian ghost
it's not it's very cold and terrible
and the gulags are there which is
uh oh gosh i forgot what the acronym
stands for but i always thought the
gulag was like a russian word but it's
actually like an
acronym like uh oh really like nasa
nasa or homes for the uh
great lakes the gulag was um like a
thick stew that they serve over
that's goulash and that's in hungary do
they serve goulash in the gulag
does that be frank i don't know if they
really like hey what are you serving
today they're more like
hey i wonder if i can catch a rat and
actually eat something is it that bad
over there like they don't get three
squats three hots and a cotton [ __ ]
i don't think they do so you can't like
build a friendship with uh your prison
guard and [ __ ] no
we're not gonna see any uh what was it
final miles or green miles yeah
thanks yeah i don't think style
sometimes it feels good to drink
beer on the rooftop
get busy
get busy living but get busy dying
and andy dufresne of it
short film by wrestling director
in one of the coldest places on earth
and it's cold in the summer it reached
100.4 degrees there
very very hot in siberia in siberia what
happened to the siberian tigers were
they like meow
yes that's exactly what they were like
[ __ ] it yeah so that was another benefit
of
2020 well they're using that as a fact
to convince a lot of different
countries in the climate agreement that
aren't in the paris climate agreement
that things are getting very very
serious and they have to do something
now that we don't have
the 10 years that people thought we'd
have or the 30 years that it's really
happening now
and it's scary and the ice caps are
melting and they're
releasing bacteria that's you know a
hundred thousand years old and all sorts
of terrible things are going on but the
good news is
people are starting to listen based on
that fun fact from 2020
no that's [ __ ] scary is that a
factual thing is that something science
is worried about science
they hope a lot of people are worried
about it and um the
irony is a lot of the cause of global
warming is the burning of
fossil fuels at one point may have been
dinosaurs
so we're using fossilized fuel
dinosaurs to heat up the earth to melt
the dinosaur bacteria that's going to
kill us
meanwhile the dinosaurs are in heaven
like ah
and then god's like what are you doing
here that i don't exist and they're like
what
what one of them has to go away
who's it gonna be andy
dinosaurs versus jungles in a bloody
battle in the heavens man
with robotron fighting on the side of
the chest
i think peter's like i'm going over the
other side and joining the dinosaurs
oh my god [ __ ] suddenly people would
be way more interested in the bible
because they're like there's some new
[ __ ] going on
it's like with star wars we only had
like three star wars movies
now you got the mandalorian and [ __ ]
that's what they got to do for the bible
and delorean of sorts the century
where he's just like got it you know
[ __ ] like
told christ people give the [ __ ] back
he's being hung
so he has to live forever like in that
movie the [ __ ]
seventh seal uh-huh he's just roaming
the galaxy and what not he finds baby
yoda you know just cross it over
because kids love a dinosaur and
half the country loves a jesus so you
put them two together
and you sell them tickets like crazy and
ultimately
like it's like you know for the
transformers like nobody you know
we it don't matter who wins or loses we
all win
well so you want to make it serious i
was thinking more like gags like you
know the dinosaurs are chasing jesus
and he like turns around and starts
laughing and they're like what are you
laughing at jesus and he says
look down and they're standing on water
and they splash down into the water and
he's like
i'm good oh and then [ __ ] like we do
a needle drop a little
fireworks the jet goes over people like
[ __ ] jet
uh no andy we can't make jokes it's
jesus
you gotta treat it seriously so this
ain't a comedy we're just showing him
not only is he all these dinosaurs
powerful in my [ __ ] father's name i
strangle you and he [ __ ] kills the
tyrannosaurus rex
with his bare hands it's two minutes
long you have to watch jesus
beat a tyrannosaurus rex to death
but then he doesn't move where he stands
to the tyrannosauruses rex foot and
stands back
and with his little teeny arms he's
trying to beat him and he can't even
reach
and reach him yeah they're too small
just punching him over and [ __ ] over
again
just until the [ __ ] finally you see
like the thing spasm and then
[ __ ] give out and whatnot and then
he's just like you've just been
t-rexed
and then then jesus walks away and does
that
you know very meaningful walk and the
t-rex rises up again and jesus turns
around and shoots him
no way jesus turns around walks away
and then you see one set of footprints
but then you're like what and the t-rex
is like
he's like that's when i carried you but
no more
any [ __ ] slap ducks him on the
floor because you have to have
compassion on a human soul jesus if he
was fighting a person
he'd let him live like in daniel son in
kk2 story you know [ __ ] style karate
kid too
but if you're jesus fighting a [ __ ]
cold-blooded
giant lizard yeah that like you know
they're like you know [ __ ]
their big gripe is like we were the
first created by your dad and then we
were replaced by the humans
so it's like that angel thing again
that's a hot [ __ ] i'm telling you you
could sell toys for that and [ __ ] like
that
and it's not like anybody owns jesus so
you can make jesus action figures all
day long
you don't even have to get anybody and
nobody owns dinosaurs we're going to be
rich
okay but we got to make the movie first
i think that's
the soros don't set up the marketing
plan before we have the movie
jesus saurus
um jesus rassic
park how about nazareth park
prince of peace vs lizard king yeah
that's a subtitle obviously we still
need a brand name for the franchise
and i mean how big are we gonna make
this is it gonna be like act three
suddenly they're just all ganging up on
him and just out of the
sky comes the holy ghost
and you better believe you better
believe every good guy from the bible
like [ __ ] sooner or later shows up
and [ __ ] because we're building toward
this massive franchise
this mass of the crossover bible movie
so they'd all have powers like job's
power would be that he's just bad luck
wherever he is she's like sorry about
this
and then like they hit with a rock or
something but a safe hits their head and
they're like
what are these pianos doing here in
seven little door opens and you see the
person inside and they're like joel
good job
hey man it's me kevin smith have you
been looking for all my old podcasts the
ones i started recording back in 2007
well guess what i found them they're all
hiding
in that kevin smith club see all the
video you've never seen including
exclusive movies and live
shows you want some swag that kevin
smith club is making pins
and miniature versions of my old scripts
if you want to be involved in the least
exclusive
most inclusive club on the net join that
kevin smith club
now's your chance to club kevin smith
all right are we done with this those
are the only good things coming out of
2020
well almost done because i do want to
mention
because in 2021 we break the rule of
three i guess that's the idea we've
already broken the rule of three and
it's another three
we just again we're slipping facts in
it's just a tiny moment
of me saying a fact and then you
completely forget it and then you make
something up about it i know that's why
we can only
do three all right well we know how this
movie ends
your lcd screen next year may be made
out of recycled fish scales
you remember i got ketchup essential
you're gonna make my tv out of
the ketchup that hines himself first
tasted
well the scales because the scales are
actually something you don't eat from
the fish
is that right i don't even look it i
don't eat anything from the [ __ ] fish
you can keep it all you filthy [ __ ]
fish eater
sticking your head in the ocean and just
biting anything swims by like a [ __ ]
big old buyer
no way not for this little black duck
um but you're not happy i mentioned this
fact
you could say that to me what is uh what
do you mean you don't need the scales
every fish you do
take the skins just scrape off the
scales and
throw them away curiosity why do they
not taste because they don't taste good
they're there to protect the fish it's
like
you don't eat the fur on a on an animal
when
oh okay fair enough when you but i mean
so when you say you take the scales off
is that just the top layer do you take
the whole skin off a fish
you don't take the whole skin off some
fish you cook it with the skin on but
you do take the scales off and those
scales
are a wasted product and these guys
figured out a way to make them into
lcd monitors that's genius they did that
over the break
like during 2020 yeah during 2020 they
were like
you guys you guys take care of that
science is going to focus on turning
fish scales into lcd monitors
or they were just like [ __ ] bored me
too
like hey man do you ever turn tv you
ever turn fish scales into a tv
no sitting there smoking weed watching
tv going you know what i hate
throwing away fish scales you know what
i'd love to watch this [ __ ] show on
the back of a majestic
marlin you pick a fish that doesn't have
scales
marlins don't have scales no marlin and
tuna
have just a a a very strong skin but
they don't have scales on them
so you catch up tuna you just start
eating the [ __ ] out of it you ain't got
to scale it
you bite its head off and be like ah you
can watch it bite its face and then look
into
its eyes as it [ __ ] dies and she'd
show its own face
is that that what you mean it looks at
you and says
life was exhausting finish it
might not be a bad way to go man we were
just like
there goes my face it's gonna turn into
poo this creature's poo
unbelievable i thought so special and
i'm just turning into this creature's
poo
but i guess that was always gonna be
some creatures poo worms maggots what
have you
i just had no idea i would watch the
thing that was gonna eat me
in real time and have these thoughts as
i passed this one and only life
could have thought about my loved ones
but instead preoccupied by the horror
and freakish sight
of a thing that ate my lower face while
my upper face watched
you're right i'm glad you did more than
three
sometimes you gotta trust me kevin
sometimes
ah
there he is there is he without me there
kevin doesn't have to wear his mask
so he can smoke as much as he likes it's
just so horrific
eating your [ __ ] lower face
wow holy [ __ ] how was it
how was it tastier for you to do that
while i'm living and also presumably
well i mean we're taking it back to fish
so these this is fish we're fighting
but they can't scream i guess if they
could scream it'd be a horrifying notion
but could you imagine if somebody was
like holding you some giant species
like they're trying to bite into your
lower face but you're like
you're trying to scream and duck being
chewed bitten off knowing that like your
chances are like
even if you avoid it for a few seconds
it's gonna happen
fucker's so big he's holding you could
bite your head off so at least he's
starting with your mouth but how
horrifying that you get to watch your
own demons
right well i'm going to explain by the
way that tunas can often be very big
like a bluefin tuna can be over 500
pounds
oh what the tunas are like fish
no they're not handheld they can be
industrial sized as well
i'm incredibly ignorant here we go i'm
teaming what i realized i have no idea i
don't know about
anything that are that big i thought you
never liked small fish
they're huge they can be very big and
you know what they were small enough to
stick in a can
oh it's a sardine no they put tunas in
cans but they put
just little parts of tuna like four
ounces of tuna tuna's like that's only
my leg
they need more canned than that from his
leg
you really don't know anything about
tunas do you they need a lot more can
than that if they want to put my dick in
there since they're untuned and [ __ ] and
it's like
bro like say what you need to to
get up and swim in the morning but we
all know that pcu is in one of them cans
which means some person which means it's
coming out as poo
very soon well i want you ain't no snake
you ain't gonna grow that park back
dirty little fish it's gone forever and
you watched it happen with your own
fishy eyes
well what i was going to say i was going
to get to
a term that is used on fishing boats
that i think you might like but it
probably you'll misinterpret it
time to eat their faces
that is why because tunas are so large
that's why on many fishing boats
yes they can't haul them in over the
gunnels
they have to use what's called a tuna
door
a tuna door tuna door oh my god do you
do you use the tuna door to access the
zoom room
i thought you would go nuts with tuna
door like that was a term for something
else but
i guess i was wrong i'm not the pig that
you are apparently i didn't read tuna
door and instantly think of a woman's
nethers andrew
i didn't either i thought of you i
thought of
the porno that we all want to see back
it's about that same tuna who's got a
piece of amount in a can somewhere he's
always bragging about how much
[ __ ] cans they need to just can his
dick
and it's about his adventures out there
and like him trying to get laid
and it really it cut you know because
he's more comedic relief
it's him watching a bunch of other fish
[ __ ] get it on
yeah he can be a part of it or jerking
off of course and then he decides he's
gonna have some anal and so he grabs his
cheek
and he's like and then he's
he's jerking off so hard he strips his
own scales
and sometimes makes a tv out of it
he's like watch this watch [ __ ] lost
on your dick
about that and your fish scales ripped
from your dick
and reduced the fish's own dignities
like that was my plan all along
he's in such denial of everything but
that's what he's
deep inside he's like my [ __ ] fish
dick hurts my fish stick hurts my mrs
paul
hurts that's a thing that's fish slang
for their dicks they call them you know
in britain you know they call
fish sticks they call them fish fingers
do they really yeah
i like fish dicks better i know you like
fish dicks
you like fish dicks if i if they ever
make another nemo
i'm pitching that joke or i'm like let
them call their dicks
mrs paul's yeah so they're all like ow
he kicked me and my mrs paul's like fish
don't have feet who's getting kicked
here
i'm like i mean i don't know it's a
cartoon right there like did you even
see the other nemo movies mr smith your
next note that we should call it
grinding nemo is completely not a disney
idea
which what was it blinding or grinding
grinding grinding nemo
like it's the story of catsup it's a
story of american
innovation because this little fish gets
ground up into cats up
and then old man heinz tastes them and
says
this would be better with
and then he goes back to america and he
creates the first bottle of ketchup
and so nemo trilogy ends on a bottle of
ketchup and that bottle of ketchup
is in the restaurant of ratatouille boom
and that's how catch-up was made
all right well that's the last fact i'm
going to give you from that and i'm
going to calm down a little bit
we can let 2020 end 2020 is over folks
because the sigh is over now we head
into the phi
what happens in the phi andy well you
know that that iron man
glove that we talked about in the last
part can't stop thinking about wanting
to jerk off with it i know you
i'm sorry to distract you with it i know
you just moved on to
grinding nemo but um we uh
it made me think of a fun comic book
slant
on all of these crazy
weapons that are being made weapons are
so advanced now there's so many weird
weapons from darpa so i came up with a
list of weapons and you have to tell me
whether this is a weapon
that exists in the real world is only
comes from a comic book
you're prepared to learn because you're
speaking to me on my level
we're not going to be keeping score
because i'm sure
you do this for me when i was in
catholic school why was i always
jesus this and the devil that why didn't
somebody just say like we're going to
talk about lightsabers that's how i got
smart the first time
movie smart and [ __ ] so comic book
weapons
or real weapons okay and i'm not worried
about the score on this because i think
you're going to ace it
so i'm going to say cb
is short for comic book because i don't
want to waste everybody's time
and then irl for in real life meaning
that is the weapon that weapon's real so
cb an irl of instinctions
i'm just thinking of the time we saved
by you shortening it to its initials
thank you for that mr smith well
um the first one is the sonic
devastator okay this is a weapon that
emits ultra uh what is it
uh low freq ultra ultra strong low
frequency waves
that can just uh cause people to
lose their mind or go nuts or make them
go deaf without hearing
anything and it works from from a long
distance away is that a comic book
weapon
like a power that somebody has or a
chemical weapon or is that something
that happens in real life
one more time with the name the sonic
devastator
there was a comic book called sonic
disrupter and and
that is a that's a sci-fi tech
i've read an article that was just about
a guy that goes to sonic and it's like
hey do you serve fish here no
no this is the home of the [ __ ] free
and i came to get me a goddamn milkshake
and i
wear the [ __ ] ass because i'm a sonic
disrupter
this is a food town will you please head
out um
so i say
i read the article about like the cats
who were over in
you know um was it cuba or
some foreign country and they got their
[ __ ]
essentially microwaved they it was
microwaves in that case not a sonic
weapon
i'm going to say this is a sonic
devastator
it sounds very comic book i'm going to
say comic book no i'm sorry that's a
real weapon
the [ __ ] yes somebody agreed to call
somebody
like is that an american weapon somebody
agreed to call it it's an american
weapon and it was first
used in uh irl just to save a little
time there because
irl as you all know means in real life
so irl yes uh
against the crowd the protesters in
ferguson in 2014
it was used on american citizens the uh
militarization of the police
they used this uh high-tech weapon and
it has been
misdubbed the uh what is it the brown
ray because um during testing it does
make people
wet themselves whenever they get hit
with this sound and
one person pooped themselves but
generally it doesn't make does not make
people poo
uh so why not the golden ray the golden
ray
that's not everywhere only if only one
guy pooped
and everyone peed i can't believe the
poop gets the brown rather the
distinction
i know it's just i think that's the
trump card you play like
it only takes one poo it depends
anyway oh boy thank you all right so
one i'm incorrect it doesn't matter
it's all in good fun i think if we're
not careful we may have learned
something here
maybe you but this is my brand if people
like he don't know that in a comic book
weapon why do i listen to his other
comic book thoughts
kevin smith does not speak for me and my
brand is forever tarnished because of
some silly game that we play
well if i could have done anything today
i guess that would be it
um the next one is the photon shield and
that is a shield where you activate it
in a handle and it
creates a shield of what is called
coherent light which is sort of like the
lightsaber that was developed in 1990
or 2016.
but this one forms a shield instead of
being a like cutting device
no that doesn't exist can you name the
comic book that it comes from
uh what is it a photon shield the photon
shield
i mean don't they use those in star trek
we have four photon torpedoes but
they have photon torpedoes and then they
have they do have shields but this comes
from captain america where in 1998
they made the misstep of replacing his
shield because
people were tired of it i don't know why
would you replace the shield
i'll tell you why in a second but what
they replace it with with
with the photon shield have you not been
listening so it was light
based or something like that so it
didn't exist he would just turn it on
and so
turn it on and he's got a shield and
then so i guess he can like keep in his
pocket instead on a backpack
why do that number one fun to draw
number two we've been telling captain
america stories for
tens of thousands of years at this point
yeah dinosaurs 100 [ __ ] years since
the dinosaurs are fighting out jesus so
uh comic books are always uh act two
you know the origins already happened
you never want to get to the end and
[ __ ] so you're constantly it's a soap
opera you're constantly looking for
content so that would kill a couple
months right like the [ __ ] shield's
gone and then
it creates sales when you're like the
shield's back
ladies and gentlemen so you create your
own problem and then you solve your
problem
that's classic comic books right there
so okay
well that's where it comes from um
how about this i got on my comic book
high horse there i was like i know
i didn't i don't know your entertainment
show there's a real reason for this
irl which means